welcome to this video presenting a game
just one game not who around of the
group B of the top of steer 2014
tournament it's not really called the B
group anymore it's called the Tata Steel
challengers group yeah the sign of the
times there's no thing as a B group sort
of implying that this is just the second
best and we have challenges and masters
and stuff like that well nevertheless
it's a very interesting tournament a
very nice combination of experience and
mostly youth because there are some very
promising juniors in the B tournament
but we also see that the Dutch yeah I
guess I you can call him a living legend
young team on is doing a great job in
the in the challenges now I think he's
on short shared a third place yeah
playing an excellent chess ready but
let's get to the game that I'm going to
show it this was played around ten just
yesterday
no no this is wrong I think it wasn't
Wednesday on Wednesday or so I'm pretty
a pretty new game and the two players I
can briefly introduce to you the white
players borrowed abhava from Georgia
long time number one of this country
he's known as a very inventive and sharp
player he's played all kinds of openings
one be three in this tournament and then
castling long quickly very wild stuff
and he's also known for preparing
dangerous opening lines at times
as the number of very good scarves him
for instance in the 2010 if I'm not
mistaken Olympiad he beat Magnus cars
very convincingly on the white side of
as a mesh nimzo-indian in fact
yeah so dangerous and very good player
he's leading in the in the B group one
of the leaders and the black player you
probably don't know so well it's a Dutch
junior player I think he's 18 years old
now and he's um if you look at the
rating he's yeah slight underdog here in
this game but okay it's a junior play
and very strong I mean I'm playing him
in the Dutch league for years
- and Belgium League and I have seen him
play many times many I mean book the
very promising player in fact he only
the day before this game was played he's
caught in this B tournament after nine
rounds he scored his final Grandmaster
norm so that he will get the GM title at
the next possible opportunity when feed
has got one of their congresses and you
see in the rating he's got to 560 is
clearly a 5 to 5 it took him a while to
score this final GM norm it's often a
matter not of accessibility but of nurse
and then some luck and it took him a
while and I can also say that he's a
very very sharp player I mean like it's
not like it's not a maniac but he's a
very good calculator and I've seen him
playing very complicated games like open
sicilians where both Kings are under
fire and so on so a very good matchup
here let's see what happened this is to
be expected Bach is always playing a 5
and he's playing various defenses to the
royal pass but Joe Brahma is playing
something different now is playing
Bishop to e2 and I must admit that
during my now years of playing e45 I
have never encountered that but it's of
course um yeah the possible set up we
see quickly what happens Knight f6 and
d3 is what is just playing out to d5 92
he's playing the Philidor just with
white and being a tempo up of course
this is not the opening that you can win
quickly but with but yeah what exactly
is an opening that you that you can do
the do it after against good defense
especially after a 45 it's very very
tricky to get any edge against the
Berlin defense for example in their way
and that the the trend really shifts
towards getting just playable positions
and try to complicate matters later this
is really a trend that now world
champion Magnus Carlsen has served as
some yeah brought into chess and I think
it's a very welcome thing to to observe
that people are not relying on
reproducing
yeah Ages of computer analysis that they
somehow produced at home and then only
need to remember that at the board so we
just play a game and I think that's very
positive um yeah I think and want to
concentrate on the latest stages of this
game so I'm not going to look at every
move in so much detail on here a5 is
very sensible because white intended to
play before getting space on the
queenside so a5 is a good prophylactic
move against that white played a 4 yeah
this is one possible response to a5
white has various ideas he can also go
for a very slow approach on the Queen
side with b3 a3 and prepare before later
this isn't an alternative d4 has a
different idea it wants to fight for the
light squares more like this and this
castles yeah both sides castle rupee 8
this is very very similar to them really
to the to the normal Philidor position
this is just the same thing with colors
reversed and
the extra tempo is probably a three year
yeah age six this is both useful
Quincy tune it's not really much
happening rookie one yeah black if you
had Cheetos with p6 Bishop b7 completing
its development and white gets the night
over to g3 this is a very typical
maneuver and this is especially
attractive in a position where black has
switched this bishop from the original
c8 square simply because on c8 it always
gots their five square so this night on
g3 now is quite nicely placed and
sometimes can really join the action on
f5 yeah this is also a black place 97
controlling the vital square and
switching over the night possibly to to
g6 because they have this it's it's a
symmetrical position here on the on the
kingside so this makes sense and night
h4 white plays against this 96 i DM c 5
this was an additional option that like
am introduced to the game with moving
the night away from c6 very often in e4
e5 positions the knight on c6 is not
well placed because it mostly looks at
those two squares and yeah they have
both controlled by the C pawn and it's
often a good idea to move it and use the
C pawn yourself as black this is also
the motivation behind the Chickering
defense of the authorial pest for
example ok c5 so what is the idea of c5
we will see that rather quickly because
Jabbar now plays Bishop g4 and this is a
move that it first took me a bit by
surprise I mean because it looks like a
bit like yeah I'm moving into thin air
it's not so clear what this Bishop is
doing on g4 it doesn't attack anything
for example it might control will c8 and
likes nitrium might take on g4 but this
is
you look at this this is mostly
strengthening White's group over at five
so taking us not really am an attractive
option
he played something else in fact he
played a very typical move played c4 and
this is well known from various F yeah
more queen like Queen pawn opening like
the old Indian
the idea is to break up the center
attacking the D pawn with the C pawn so
that like very often can exchange this
pawn against the D pond so we would have
an extra pawn in the center at the end
and we see what happens why it takes
probably necessary and now black takes
with the knight on e4 and at first this
looks quite attractive for like now he's
got a good knight on e4 and what is
White's play now he can ya consider to
take on d5 just to look at some moves
like has this option with this strong
threat Plus Knight takes d5 this is
really a big firing and white can also
take here in fact this is the yeah this
is the let's say the pedestrian way to
play this position you take with the
knight on e4 and now player developing
move on yeah or maybe Knight f5 also
possible trying to get rid of the the
edge for night and yeah this is simply a
normal position
efore is not such a weak bond and black
has has ideas Bishop c5 III email and
it's just the game but Jabbar has
entirely entirely different idea and
when I first saw that this was one of
those moments that I sometimes have in
my blitz games this is typical what
moments really is doing that and yeah
this is now the fasten your seat belts
moment he sacrificed the exchange on
e-form Luke takes a form this is only
really understandable in connection with
the next move because after the capture
forced of course um yeah now he took on
aged six and it's a bit of a shame that
we don't have the precise clock times it
would be really interesting to know how
long doc now spend on this position um
I'm not sure that the times here
accurate they they might be but this
would imply that baku yet played there
very very fast up to this point it's
possible it wasn't so difficult what
black played here but still okay but
what is the sacrifice he's just
sacrificing on age six and if black now
takes the the bishop why this let's do a
body count a whole look down it's not
just a piece or anything it's a whole
look he's got okay he's got one pawn but
it's a rook and what is the compensation
yeah well white has those three pieces
near the king at least those pieces are
approaching the king like this this but
it's it's still not so apparent what the
direct compensation is in fact when I
first looked at this I was at mine and
my my chess club and we did some
analysis without any computer assistance
which is always interesting nowadays you
are so tempted when you at home are even
if you're away if you've gotten your
smartphone available you can easily
enter any position and get some some
brief computer analysis it's very
tempting to do that but it's sometimes
really worth to just okay let's put the
computer side and analyze a bit for
yourself and I can now show you some
lines that we
that we looked at just with ya only
human only human lies and then what the
computer actually says of them about
that
so our first idea was the move Queen d2
attacking h6 of course rather obvious
move you want your queen involved
without the Queen you are never going to
checkmate black end well being a rook
down you should try to try to mate with
some slow moves you you won't won't get
anywhere and at first we thought no this
is certain is quite strong let's say if
black covers with okay this is very easy
start with that check giving you this
check check check
yeah this is this is completely winning
around so King g7 is a very very easy
move to meet King h7 it's the same it's
not the same move but it's the same case
of not being a good defense threatening
on h6 with the queen of course and d6
hangs so what is winning here but black
has a good move
he's got the move Knight to g6 and after
a minute or so we found it so at first
we thought okay and the King and so on
but not g6 is is a good defense it
detects not from c8 from here at the
text of the night and this means that
white does not have the time to take on
h6 and the knight on h4 needs to need to
move first if you take and then take
here black has Queen f6 and this is
already apparent that there's no attack
especially with those squares now
controlled white can't play something
like that but
after queen of seven he does not have
any any threat at all and in fact like I
can play Bishop c5 with counterplay or
expelled oops
expel with Bishop f8 the Queen so this
is not working at all 96 is very
convincing there is this move try that
but then Bishop f8 is a good reroofing
covering h6 something like that this is
simply simply not enough the tanks and
the Queen hangs so why even it's a
threat Queens which means Queen d2 is
not the move and this looked quite
logical getting the Queen involved then
after some thought we came up with in
fact the best move with rook t1
oops 41 and and here we analysed a lot
or much deeper and in fact the the best
move we didn't find at all that only was
possible for me afterwards with with
computer assistance I can show you what
move we we did analyze and we concluded
that black should be okay after that and
this is something really we we managed
to find a line that is really is good
for black but it's not the best line
I'll show you our idea was to play e
oops
III year the idea is simply to to
activate you activate your Bishop and
after the capture it's not so easy to
not capture on e3 I can show briefly if
Y divides it but after the capture our
idea was to play d4 and this now opens
up this diagonal for counter play and
it makes it difficult for the Queen to
to enter the action you can only the
Queen only can go by have to and we
thought that black should be okay here
or maybe is even better and analysis
confirms that this is in fact a playable
line for black it's not leading to a big
edge but it's playable which is a good
accomplishment for for some humans and
advising such and such a sharp position
and of course I should continue here
because it's a very interesting position
yeah
you still need to don't need to forget
or practice a rope down he needs to do
something and this is hanging a black is
really threatening to take it because
okay it would give up the Queen but
would really net so much material that
that you're out of any problems so white
needs to react to react him and what
lines are possible here white can try
this one
intending nine to h5 after that black
should play Queen c7 and just accept
this Knight f6 check the characters
after after the check and like just
secures the King yeah that after after
all that black is still a piece up and
he has gained lots of control over this
position especially considering that you
can at the right moment also use this
Bishop for checks on g3 on e5 to cover
important squares um this is some came a
good position for black here's basically
am yeah survived the tech and has this
extra material right h5 is not not
really the toughest smooth the best move
is Queen f2 covering that you always
need to remember that our
to the capture and attacking the screen
the g4 bishop is really covering d1 at
first I really forgot this and thought
okay Bishop g3 but you can simply
recapture and now why does an excellent
shape threatening all kinds of
discoveries him so Bishop g3 is of
course nonsense but black has something
better and their Queen c7 is the best
move a logical one getting out of the D
Hall and attacking the knight and here 9
h5 is very logical putting the night
near the king and introducing ideas like
Knight f6
or at the right moment Queen f6 Queen f6
Queen g7 mate would be nice but one
point of this advance what that Bishop
e5 is moving to to cover those vital
squares and of course this is what black
place now there should be five yeah how
to continue now white still has an
attack well he can play the stretch out
take him and now it's an interesting
position
what should like do in fact he has two
possibilities cm rook 88 or queen g3 of
course we are already very deep in this
line but it's very tricky and
interesting to analyze look the 8th this
fairly logical moves I think because it
tries to exchange more pieces so an
extra look for black rope d8 logical and
the look everyone is the is the best
reply after hook f8 and Queen h6 we see
that white is very close to perpetual
and in fact he's going to get it after
Bishop c8 for example there are other
moves takes takes and look at form this
idea basically forces black to play f5
after which Queen g4 check King h7
Janet's wife is drawing black cannot
check escape here Knight f5 is even
winning provide this attack as too much
getting right into the firepower of the
F file that's too much and check here
white also has this lukkage for idea so
you could at first think okay on why not
this one
it's night oops it's 96 controlling h4
so white cannot play for a win here so
on let's return here book d8 was one
move and what can also play a queen g3
this in fact seems to be better this has
some forcing character like tries to
take only three and after the capture on
e3 the Queen really would do two very
important things
covering h6 and covering b6 b6 is not so
important but if you keep h6 this is of
course huge for your King safety the
best move for white is quite obvious
should whoops should take em let me look
at my notes so many lines that I'm
getting confused to him yeah
one should take and after that queenie 5
after the white queen has left its
position on e5 black and retreat to e5
to control all those vital squares f6
and so on yeah and after everyone bishop
c8 again this idea we can continue like
that yeah it's already a very very deep
line and it's completely unrealistic to
think that someone playing black could
calculate that this is just so crazy
that I wanted to wanted to show it at
the end of all this after Queen b6 White
has seven points against four pawns so
he's got three pawns for the rook and
the position is not entirely
yeah I guess that black is better but
it's not an automatic win at all so it's
it's still it's not a game to be played
so what is the conclusion the conclusion
is that our idea with III takes and e4
is at least a playable line for black
and that leads to something between a
good position for black and unclear
however you see that from a practical
point of view this is a very dangerous
position for both sides why does the
whole look down but he has definite
attack so it's it's very difficult to
play let's return to the critical
position white had taken on aged 6 and
after the capture goes sorry after the
capture looked you one I was mentioning
that III was the idea that we had
developed with our our group of Club
mates had developed this idea and I
mentioned that the computer was able to
improve on that and the amazing thing is
that this really seems to be the best
move what the computers is giving
because I mean I'm aware that this is a
very concrete position and the computer
should be able to to calculate it
correctly but it's a matter of how much
time do you give it to really assess
what's going on so I'm going to show you
the move and I find this amazing 98 move
that the computers recommending and this
is a move that I think for a human
player is exceptionally difficult to
make simply because it retreats
basically the only piece that is near
the king you retreat it all the way back
to the Queen side and you also expose
the f5 square even more of courses
a very general statement and a position
like that depends solely on concrete
lines at calculation but still it's
means that I really think that it's very
difficult for human to consider you
might get to it if you are given lots of
time and and some yeah I've you explore
some lines without really calculating it
in your head but putting it on the board
you might get to the point where you
consider it but it's a very at least
from my kind of chess intuition a very
counterintuitive move however it seems
to be really good and I'm going to show
you some some lines one very important
point of course is that the Queen
instantly attacks the knight on H form
and this limits White's options
he cannot simply play any any slow move
he needs to address this issue of the
hanging night and there are essentially
two moves that one can try white can go
to f5 loops go to a5 immediately or you
can go to a five after capturing on c8
capturing on C aid of course it's not
the most logical move even taking this
this knight on the on the back rank but
it needs to be checked because it might
accelerate the the action so a move to
look at maybe start with that if white
takes on on F on c8 um black he has has
two replies obviously rook takes Bishop
takes and both seems both moves seem to
be okay rook c8 is the the more
convincing though as it keeps you for
covered by the bishop after Knight H
takes a five it was still hanging so you
don't really have much choice black has
to move through p6 and around here I
think it becomes apparent
that it's it's not enough firepower for
white taking only for to increase the
pressure
it just gets gets taken and it's it's no
no attack anymore simply it's simply too
little it's five maybe it's still an
important move to cover g4 but this is
simply not enough attack instead of
taking on e4 white can try of course to
to get the get the Queen over could try
that move attending Queen G for Queen
Anne's five but here black has Queen f6
not the only move but a good and logical
one gets the Queen involved to defend
and this means that again the tank is
not sufficient after Queen g4 for
example I can't even play queen g6 ummm
rooty six wait I think it's King f8
right I have a real jungle of variation
variations in my notes and once in a
while I forget what I am what I looked
at earlier yeah it's King f8 of course
and only after Knight h5f wise tries to
that there's Queen g6 yeah this this is
quite clear after after that for example
it's it's a big for cam on the two
nights yeah Bishop takes the 8 it's not
the most obvious move and that doesn't
seem to be the best one it's more
dangerous to keep pieces on the board so
night h 2f v is the it's the better
choice and here we again have a position
where like needs to find the the one
move that really secures the advantage
I think there are two obvious moves here
but only one is really really doing a
good job of of getting you close to a
real big dream the best move is Queen f6
but I'm going to show you briefly that
look e6 which is not looking stupid at
all I mean it covers h6 it covers d6
that this is not really sufficient to to
clearly win and quite amazing I think
after Knight takes e4 yeah white has
this red going or maybe maybe the other
night but well what I'm getting at is
black should probably just take it on
e-form hard to keep the knight on the
board so takes and rook b8 very logical
after that y term just continues without
really caring that he's a rook down and
it's it's a very tricky position 93
attacking here you know look f6 for
example I'm not sure for example it's
the right word black does not have much
choice rook f6 and now there are
interesting moves white can consider to
take on e5 utilizing this opinion I can
also and this is I think more
interesting you mean you can play before
just pushing pawns and the amazing thing
is it's only two pawns for a whole rook
but the position is not clear at all
because black is so poorly coordinated
the pieces are so strangely placed that
you have a hard time to get everything
into play and on the other hand white
has very strong positions for his pieces
this Knight d5 being a possibility still
rook lifts and you can push the pawns
while black is just tied on
back back rank if you give it to a
computer and let it calculate this for
30 seconds or minute
well not it's not the ages yeah but it's
a decent time of calculation it gives
only a slight advantage to black like
about one pawn or 0.9 or something and
this shows that black is in some
practical at least trouble despite being
a rook down it's not easy to play
so rookie six is not this position not
losing or anything but it's it's tricky
it's a tricky game that white can really
yeah continue to play with chances the
better move is Queen f6 and to be honest
it's also the more logical one in my
opinion because you get the Queen out of
the D file and in fact after that I
failed to to find any convincing
continuation if white now takes here we
simply have a different position with
black not being in the spin and white
not being able to win a tempo with 93
here he's of course still can continue
and post problems because he has those
strong pieces and then yeah oops they
are near the King but objectively
speaking I don't think it's it's enough
the computers give black gives black
about three pawns iam so pretty much the
same result if you do a stupid body
count counting pawns of pieces so it
seems that the compensation is not
sufficient at all
I also continued some lines because it
sometimes happens that the computer is
not evaluating correctly those type of
slower texts where some site is taking
some moves to to get the pieces near the
King but
still not defensible this happens in the
Kings Indian all the time that the
computer sometimes police positions are
okay for white and then the pieces are
coming slowly towards the King and made
made white but this is not one of them
the only direct meaningful attack as
Luke d3 and g3 and I think the computer
is an ESS is that this is not a winning
continuation also important is that
black is not caught in the corner or
something but the the oops the King can
also escape on on f8 if needed so I
guess this is refutation of the bishop
takes h6 sacrifice black should take it
sorry it should take it and after Luke
d1 he must play 9 c8 and as mentioned
this is a completely at least in my
opinion counter intuitive move yeah Bach
did something else
he played Bishop c5 and now you can see
that probably the clock times are bogus
because I simply cannot believe that
here after 10 minutes that he played
Bishop c5 I don't I don't believe it
so it's just ignore the clock times I
believe that in this position black
certainly would spend some time to to
check out the capture and and simply
yeah adjust to the situation that the
opponent is just it has just played
really yeah kind of a crazy sacrifice
that you didn't expect probably ok
played Bishop c5 and what's the idea
well the idea is sum is twofold he wants
to avoid any pins on the default and he
also wants to play III to get pieces off
we see that in a moment after would get
one at Queen c7 white played the very
nice I think
static move kings queens e1 intending
Queen g5 getting the Queen quickly over
to the to the Kings side a very similar
idea to what we saw before Queen d2 here
box idea comes into play
he plays an e3 this was prepared by the
ship's e5 this is in fact not the only
rules but clearly the moves that he
intended and I think very human defense
but also need to check and move like
rook t8 opposing on the D phone and this
now leads to absolutely crazy
complications but very nice lines rook
takes and now Queen takes this is in
fact the only move rope the eight is its
losing straight away due to Queen g5
this is the only defense against the
mate and this is too much of an attack
Plus this check and the two knight moves
this is not defensible at all black must
play Queen takes and this is because you
need after Queen g5 you need this
all-important 96 maneuver but white does
not need to play Queen g5 immediately he
hasn't has another move and this is very
nice night H file I think this is just
an absolutely amazing position with
whites
- pieces of g4 h4 h5 and h6 I cannot
remember ever having seen something like
that this is just outstanding
and all our pieces are taking it's it's
it's really great yeah what what is
blacks defense IAM yeah 96's again the
move that you need to check and
yeah white should continue with the the
sharpest reply Knight f5 and now we see
that everything's on g7 and very very
hard to defend from black but he has a
defensive move and this is III again
Akeem moves you need counter play
threatening this and you need to win
some time in your defense
white takes and now Bishop ma this is
the the toughest defense and at first
you might think wait isn't this good for
black how does white continue now the
two knights are ok they were very very
aggressively placed but what is the next
move but White has a very strong move
and amazingly he can play Bishop h6
again this is just great just goes to h6
again and threatens to take on g7 so
black it's really he does not have much
choice he needs to take it now Knight is
aged 6 and here again only one move you
cannot capture after Queen takes this is
unavoidable checkmate on g7 so black
needs to move the King King h8 it's very
easy jack winning the Queen so we need
to need to go here yeah now Knight f7
attacking the Queen and the Queen does
not have many squares available if you
for example go go here yeah that's
justice check coming and look at the
King only SG 7 Candice wins everything
so the Queen needs to God f6 adhere in
this position white has a really really
great move and yeah we're going to put
it on the board Bishop e6
this is just a fantastic
fantastic chess the Queen if the Queen
takes there's Nigeria quite even wins
and what is the threat now
now white is threatening Knight g5 check
and this is a complete perpetual because
black cannot go to g8 in this position
there's simply no way to avoid the
perpetual check coming after for example
here check check check
sir this check and you need the bishop
on e6 to cover g8 if black goes here
check you have this check yeah okay what
about this check checkmate even a
checkmate yeah black cannot play for a
win you after not have three you have
again the same position leading to a
perpetual check so just a beautiful line
that is almost impossible to see
beforehand I think once you're in it
you're like in this position here you're
probably going to find there should be
six if you have some time on your hands
simply because you you need to yeah sort
of fire you last bullet and this must be
the bishop somehow but it's just an
amazing amazing line and this also shows
the enormous practical chances that
white ants in this position
he just has great compensation and I
love this position with the whole pieces
on the h1 yeah this is after rook d8
Bach plate III which is as mentioned I
think a very good practical decision
weiter no is basically forced to take
only three with the bishop and black now
gets to get rid of one pair of minor
pieces and this is of course very
helpful in defense so now here the the
next critical position in this position
in fact
on Bach now place we take C form and in
fact it seems that this move is is
really losing the game after this I
think there is no defense anymore and
this is quite remarkable that there is
absolutely no defense I mean it's not
even not the most precise movement just
the losing move I don't think you can
simply state okay this is greedy he
takes upon you should better have
defended somehow I think there's just
some case of miscalculation behind that
because the Queen on c-4 also has some
other ideas it's not just a pawn grab
can sometimes go to f4 it covers f7
stuff like that
yeah we look at this in just a minute
why this is in fact losing it was shown
nicely in the game by Joe baba why it
does what black probably should do is
look 88 and then we have a very
complicated game that could really yeah
ii ii ii to our results for example
white can play this one keep it on the
board but also take here this is the the
quickest way to attack and I think it's
probably leading to to get at least the
compensation now Quinn takes and then 9h
5 again approaching the King and this is
threatening Queen g5 again of course and
also at times Queen g3 a possible line
that is not not forced but show us a
typical way how it could could have gone
bishop c8 Queen G 396 takes takes here
and after this caption which
to be seven chess this continuation with
black intending to play tweener for this
very likely will end in a draw by a
perpetual for example after queen g6
like is basically chess - to give this
check check give this perpetual it's
just one line white also can fight maybe
this is even the more logical move he
can play a rupee one if he wants and
yeah you can analyze this on and on it's
very very tricky maybe this is the the
way to really make it big fine out of it
instead of taking on d8 it's just one
line that I have that I looked at okay
he took on c4 and as mentioned this
turns out to be the decisive mistake the
next move is relatively easy to find
nine h5 we already know this motif the
night is nearing the king and it
prepares Queen g5 I think it's just that
Bach made some calculation mistake
understandable of course but let's let's
have a look he played Queenie form maybe
he relied on this counter idea on g2
here there are of course other
alternatives one is again 96 typical
defensive move if you look at those
lines you always see that 96 is an
important defense and this what makes in
this earlier line Knight c8 so difficult
to play because you just always have
this this feeling you need you the night
near the King to defend and then the
best move is actually to retreated to c8
away from the King this makes 9 c8 very
difficult to find for human player I
think yeah let's have a look at this
Knight g6 after that white has has two
good moves actually he can play Queen g5
or in sacrifice on g7 97 is also winning
after King g7 check the check and Queen
age 6 this is impossible to defend and
and winning for white however I would
like to show the other line because it's
very nice Queen g5 is the lion I'm
referring to this is just threatening to
take and break through are taking on g7
or Knight f5 so there's so many many
ideas here but there's one very nice
line if black now tries to defend g6
with Bishop reform white is forced to
find the only means that really wins
instantly everything else is not so
clear and the move is Bishop f5 very
strong move one point of this is that
after Queen c6 white has a very strong
continuation knight c6 f g6 and now rook
d7 this is very very strong and also I
think a very attractive picture again
white having those two pieces forked and
he uses one of the pieces on f5 that is
the double detect even by this and this
it usually uses one of those pieces to
allow rook d7 a very very static Nuala I
think the point of all this is that
after the capture on f5 there's route 87
looking a fate and Queen h6 and Queen h8
made us avoidable
so in fact after group d7 black is
completely lost he has no defense after
against the capture on g7 it's just a
deadly deadly mating attack
this shows that 96 didn't really defend
and besides in ig6 and the move played
in the game there simply is nothing
Queen g5 is just just so strong he
played Queenie Freud's mentioned and
this was answered by Queen g5 of course
96 yeah we already know the idea what is
White's best move now an interesting
question here Joe baba yeah
misses the quickest way to win the game
he could have played Knight takes g7
yeah and it turns out that this would
have won even more convincing me than
what he played but of course it's not
easy at all after this capture King
takes that's nice a drive check came
back and Bishop f3 maybe this is what he
didn't see I can only speculate Ian
Bishop f3 and now with this Cabot and
the Queen attacked White's next move is
going to be Queen f6 and it's a
unavoidable mate or black needs to give
up the Queen with of course hopeless
material losses so this was very strong
if black does not capture and play
something like this then white can
already return to let's say normal play
take on f4 and take this exchange to get
to a winning endgame he is simply 2
points up now and enjoys dominating
pieces so nitrous happened was even
stronger he played the slightly weird I
think King edge to this is probably a
prophylactic move getting the King out
of possible checks on the back rank and
it seems to still converse converse
conserve and a big advantage but not g7
was
was somewhat stronger here Bakker should
have played f6 and this seems to to
defend more stubbornly he played Bishop
c8 we can have a look at f6 after f6 why
defector has has two replies to place
the obvious one twin g6 this we can
simply count pieces here White has two
two nights
for the rook and the pawn so from
material point of view why does an
excellent shape the only issue is that
this pieces are now slightly it's
slightly stranded so this is a bit bit
tricky still white should window an
alternative amazingly enough in this
position is the move through t7 and this
is in fact the roof I like I like even
more it looks a very nice in addition to
being effective if black takes the Queen
that's what she said check King f8 check
and 9tx g6 and at the end black is
forced to return the exchange him on it
same give up the Queen so that at the
end we have a position where white is an
exchange down but he has very strong
compensation for for it because of the
pawns he is attacking g5 his attacking
b6 all blacks pawns are weak and why it
still has some attack going 90 f6 and so
on White is in excellent shape here it's
I guess a matter of taste I think both
continuations are excellent for white
and very close to winning if not winning
still f6 was the the tougher defense
Bach played Bishop c8 and now it's it's
it's it's really a quick loss played f3
there was also Luke t6 immediately but
he inserted f3 queen takes and
thirty-six it doesn't make much of a
difference and now the pressure on on g6
is far too far too big black and can
never take care of course checkmate
very simple mate and white is just
threatening to take g6 and break through
and here there's absolutely no defense
he took on g4 just recaptures and now
try it
King age seven and this now led to a
cute finish night g 6f g6 and now White
has forced made already some Maidan I
think five minutes he played Knight f6
check check
takes of course the only move if like
the king checkmate
it's instant mate so took it just check
he moves okay you can insert Ruby seven
desperado but it's not really helping
okay this this was pure droid Queen f6
and now there's Queen g7 with a mate and
this is absolutely not defensible we see
in this position that the move like King
edge - that looks a bit mysterious
really does have its points just imagine
the King being on g1 then black would
have Queen c1 check King edge - Queen f4
and black wins okay this is just it's
not the position that could could appear
on the board but it shows that the slow
move a defensive move like King edge -
can be very very important at times so
YTM has this made thread and it's not
defensible so Bach who signed the game
yeah an absolutely fantastic game I
think a very surprising sacrifice by
Jabbar and I don't really know how many
people would even consider the idea to
take with rook here and take one h6 it's
just just amazing to see this this
kind of chess being played in the top
grandmaster game you know the analysis
supported or checked with an engine
shows that like probably could have
taken and maybe after rook t1 and the
and my book not very intuitive move
Knight c8 maybe he would have gotten a
decisive advantage and won the game but
it's very difficult to play it's not a
game that is played by computers so it's
it's it's difficult to do in practice
and I think it's it's very
understandable how Bach defended yeah I
think we should c5 and this idea to play
III to get pieces office it's a very
decent one and it was only here that he
made the decisive mistake with Knight
takes e4 which allowed this dandy attack
starting with Knight h5 yeah I hope you
enjoyed this this game I think it was
really great
also some lines that we could explore
are exceptionally attractive to to look
at yeah I hope you enjoyed it I'll be
back tomorrow
with coverage from the next to last
round of the a group right how is it
coming out the masters right the the big
the big guns
here's the cold a group okay well I hope
you liked it thanks for watching and
yeah let's talk again tomorrow bye